One of my favorite apps is the Philosophical calculator. Like
a normal calculator, the first step is to give it
some input. Here, we're going to say, Right, a guy
In Act 4. We could also supply files
But in this case, we're going to go with a
simple prompt. Now the first step in using the philosophical
calculator, of course, is to make sure we have some
models selected. We're going with haiku and Gemini flash image
And then we start at the pipeline. Since our input
is fairly small, we're going to skip the summarized notes
part and go straight to draft article. We can run
that in the UI and wait for it to complete
We could view this session. To monitor it in real
time, but this processing session is a one-stop operation. Its
details aren't particularly interesting. For session detail
we will view that in depth when we execute lenses
which is next. But for now, We
have the completed draft article. That is shown in a
formatted preview. And now that we have the draft article
we can proceed to lenses. Here's where it gets really
interesting. The philosophical, philosophical calculator provides a variety
you can perform on your draft article. It performs a
variety of different analyseses like brainstorming or multi-perspective analysis
or even writing a comic book about the article. For
demonstration purposes, let's go with perspective analysis. I'm
going to click run, and in a second, a session
link will pop up. This session link allows us to
monitor the Multi-perspective analysis task
in real time as it proceeds through a multi-step reasoning
The user interface you're seeing here is the standard user
interface for real-time. Um Agents
because it will be going through a number of different
perspectives and then finally it will synthesize the results, basically
summarize all of the perspectives. We can also in
the main UI go over to usage and we can
monitor the usage as it Uses tokens
So far we have spent about 4 cents on this
process. Oh, the brains, the multi-perspective dialogue is ongoing
so it just used another penny. And
when it completes, the UI will Update. We're only going
to run this one lens to demonstrate this module, but
you could run each of these, um, if you wanted
to in parallel. Depending on what you felt was appropriate
when these are completed, we can then go back to
the pipeline. And we can update the article which will
take the output of all of the lens runs and
try to fold them back into the article to Pick
up insights and new ideas and other things like that
Perhaps correcting issues. Looking
at lenses, this is kind of almost complete. I saw
a synthesis here. Synthesis is. The last step in the
synthesis is the last step in the multi-perspective analysis. There
we go. And we can see the detailed output for
a given. lens run in the UI. Here we see
the multi-perspective analysis transcript, which will detail. Each
perspective in turn. For example, this is
the competitive player perspective. It goes through each perspective, so
it's quite a long analysis, and at the end, you
will find The synthesis and recommendations
section. Here we go. So the lenses
generally involve a very long Set of analysis
and then they conclude with a summary. Those summaries and
analysises can again be folded back into the original article
using the pipeline. However, for brevity's sake, we will skip
that and demonstrate one last feature, the illustrate article feature
which is, I think, one of the most entertaining. This
takes your content in your article and designs a number
of illustrations. It can then weave into the article for
um, there's a display issue. The session link is
shown. In the draft article section. Hopefully that will
be fixed and really soon. And again we can monitor
this in real time. It comes up with the Asia
And then after it generates each image. After it generates
all of the images, it will It
will integrate the images into the original documents by. And
now we see our article. Full of illustrations. For
62 cents, we have a fully illustrated guide to Connect
Four. This of course is merely
a demo. I hope you enjoy this tool and exploring
your own ideas.